[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday April
25th Judy Blume that's weird
I admit it you admit it we admit it
we're weird Helen Hunt and Judy Blume
are weird people to have in your guilt
free free guilt free free weird people
to have in your guilt free three
especially since I only have one person
in my guilt free three captain is known
about this for a long time she doesn't
like it but they're haters out there you
can't help it you can't help who's on
your guilt free three and so for Helen
Hunt who deserves to be on guilt free
threes all over the nation I've written
a song
[Music]
time I saw you was the day that I hit
puberty played a beautiful girl shunned
by society it was a year
you just smoke one laced doobie that
after-school special made me want to
never do PCP Alan hunt and hunt you make
my heart do acrobatic stunts you stand
and face the front of the twister of my
burning want Helen Hunt you
about you
I saw you naked and the water dancing
was as good as it gets in my pants
with that I really want to thank you
your husband's name was Hank right well
my name is Hank to Helen Hunt
huh you make my heart dry prophetic
stunts you stand and face the brunt of
Twister of my burning Ellen hunting oh
I'm mad about you
once the next best friend of mine said
he couldn't see how an old and ugly
actress could mean so much to me
him bleeding in the snow I asked him who
was best comedy actress four years in a
row Helen Hunt Helen Hunt you make my
heart do acrobatic stunts he stand and
face the front of Twister of the burning
one Helen Hunt you know I'm mad about
you
but you know I mad about I just watch
that video all the way through and it's
really really creepy oh my god I'm the
creepiest of them all why do I spend so
much time on these things some days I
just got a little carried away okay
sorry
take that all you people who think that
there's no reason to love Helen Hunt
she made me want to never do PCP Helen
if you're watching this I'm not that
scary now that that's done with I'll see
you tomorrow